[Music]
hi everybody for Atlanta hey Reuben boy
dudu BAM looks like it's a little cold
out there right yeah we got some snow
this morning I'm here on the set of our
film this is our San Francisco set which
as you know is also where Eddie Brock is
from up until this point we've had a
completely closed set
no visitors no press nobody's been here
so you guys are the first people in the
entire world to visit our stages we have
a couple of questions for you
kenna tell us a little about the movie
cuz anyone who's read the comics has
seen a lot of different vanos throughout
the years and which iteration of the
character will be in this movie well we
want to be as true as possible to the
comics with our film but our story is
primarily based on the lethal protector
and the planet of the symbiotes books
and can you give us a little hint of
what fans can expect to see in venom
sure I can promise you badass action
Venom's dark humor and I can also
promise you and absolutely stunning
performance by Tom Hardy
this is Venom's movie so we never know
where he's going to show up we're
creating the next link in the chain
yeah I thought I'd introduce you to my
good friend Tom Hardy here my partner in
crime
aka Eddie Brock
Wow a lot of people Wow hey I am so
sorry that I can't be with you we were
going to actually surprise you but
flying in we're gonna take the flight
it's like nine and a half hours
overnight and then we're gonna jump back
and go back to set but uh
the snow kept us on the ground so I'm
really sorry that we can't be there with
you now wow we wanted to come to South
Powell and we wanted to come to Brazil
I've never been I'm a huge fan so anyway
I just wanted to say that I give you my
word of honor that I'm going to do
everything I can to deliver the best
venom that I possibly can muster because
I know how important he is to you and I
know how important he is to the Marvel
Universe I don't know how important this
is for all of us here so that's what
we're doing and anyway since I can't be
there I've got one of these really cool
t-shirts right which is the only bit of
official memorabilia there anybody I've
modified mine you're gonna have to
modify your own but we left you one each
and the guys will be giving you one and
it's got the Brazilian flag on
if you can see that but that's for you
thank you so much Sao Paulo I'm sorry
that we can't be with you and I well
maybe next time
[Applause]
save some
same Saffiano
we
we are
[Applause]
[Music]